a world connected by flight paths
defying distance to bridge gaps between
continents and people but planes also
made it possible for viruses to travel
faster than ever before that turned a
local outbreak into a global pandemic
the airline industry was knocked out of
the sky around 90% of flights canceled
globally some airlines couldn't survive
things are slowly taking off again but
the future of aviation looks very
different health screening has become as
important as security screening social
distancing in once crowded Airport
terminals and on board may be the new
normal but how will the new normal
ensure protection from a deadly virus
that hasn't gone away welcome to our
Cobie 19 special on DW news I'm Monica
Jones in Berlin and the last time I
traveled by plane was in March Tsar's
Cove 2 had just started to spread in
Germany and planes were soon grounded
while now restrictions are being lifted
and people are slowly taking to the
skies again but is it safe birds
chirping at the EU largest Airport
Paris's Xiao de Gaulle an unusual
silence where thirteen hundred flights
used to take off and over two hundred
thousand passengers transit each day we
saw a 98 percent fall in passenger
numbers since the lockdown measures
began to be eased we felt things moving
a bit last week we had an average of
around 10,000 passengers per day which
is about 20 percent more than the
previous week it's much less than last
year but we see an increase and some
movement on the passenger side in China
where the pandemic first broke out the
low point was mid February with only 23
percent of the normal flights that is
now stabilized at around 60 percent
compared to the previous year but the
industry fears passenger numbers will
never reach the same
levels of passengers need a good reason
to travel at the moment we expect new
measures from the government starting
June the 15th we now have passenger
restrictions until that date and we
expect a resumption of flights in the
Schengen area on the 15th but before
that happens
passengers have to feel safe it would
take years to equip aircraft with new
seating plans and may never happen given
the air carriers tight budgets for the
time being
travelers will need to bring a lot more
patients with them in Delhi baggage is
disinfected outside the terminal all
passengers are checked for a temperature
negative Corona tests could be added to
the list for passengers boarding in some
countries seating on this flight is
socially distanced the flight attendants
uniforms are also different so
experience wise to just sum it up if you
ask me this is yes it is overall
different because we are not used to
coming to work like this and the job
isn't over once the flight lands this
cleaning team in Delhi has to completely
disinfect the aircraft so is the
coronavirus the kiss of death for air
traveling or can we reduce the risks of
catching a dangerous disease let's bring
in Professor Ashok Srinivasan from the
department of computer science at the
University of West Florida good to have
you with us and understand that you are
the principal investigator of new
research on pedestrian dynamics models
and that has recently been used in the
analysis of procedures to reduce the
risk of disease spread in airplanes in
terms of health how risky is it to fly
well if you look at one specific flight
or one specific individual on a
particular flight the risk of infection
is not very high however considering
there are so many travelers and so many
flights it's inevitable at some time or
the other that'll be a major outbreak on
the flights similar thing happen in SARS
also
so there are most of the flights known
in fact with anyone else but there are a
few flights where a lot of people got
infected so so the risk of getting
infected on a plane isn't higher than
let's say are on a train or any room
that is closed yeah correct I don't want
to give exact numbers because in a new
outbreak it's always very difficult to
predict what's going to exactly happen
but because of a large number of flights
you have a high probability of some
outbreak or that are happening over the
whole system all right well let's take a
closer look at this
SARS co2 virus because obviously one way
to reduce the risk of catching the virus
is social distancing that is pretty
impossible on a plane isn't it oh well
social distancing is not a
all-or-nothing thing it's not like for
example they're acting up talking about
the six feet threshold however if you
are much closer the probability of
infection is much higher and sometimes
you can get you can catch it even if
your father away so do certain things
you know for example some airlines
removing the people in the middle seat
so that increases social distancing a
bit if you look at a passenger you know
they can when boarding they can actually
try to maintain distance for example if
you bought lost you can try to maintain
distance at the previous person and you
have some control over what happens okay
so if everybody boards last then the
plane will never take off and leaving
out the middle seat is is obviously not
very cost-effective for the airlines you
did a lot of research certainly in the
way that humans behave in in sort of
narrow passageways and you used Frontera
which is one of the world's most
powerful supercomputers how did this
computer help you with your simulations
and what were your findings well one of
the observations is that human behavior
is very hard to predict so if you look
at if you look at one particular
simulation or two three simulations
and try to see what will humans do you
have probably not going to capture all
possibilities especially major infection
outbreak an extreme event so to capture
that you need to look at all possible
ways in which humans actually behave so
we to do the simulation we did millions
of simulations so that takes a lot of
computation effort so that is the reason
we had to use a supercomputer because we
want to look at extreme events where
some unlikely situation leads to a major
infection outbreak now given that a lot
of people are starting to fly again
because planes are no longer grounded
you already said it's a good idea to be
the last on board that might not always
be possible anything else we should bear
in mind is there a particular safe seat
or row especially when we think of air
ventilation and and droplets that carry
viruses and them floating around
well theoretical models suggest that
sitting in the aisle seat is most
dangerous because one is you're close to
people who are actually walking in the
aisle and also the our circulation most
of the planes takes the Earth from the
window side into the aisle side it some
planes it differs but on the whole it
tends to move the ad towards the person
on the aisle which infections in
increase the infection probability yep
yeah please go on well in fat outbreak
though one of the major outbreaks
actually it was equally spread between
aisle window and the middle seat so it's
not guaranteed that if you sit in the
aisle you are going to have a higher
probability and if you're in the window
you'll have a lower probability however
it has some modeling support and some
common sense that window would be a
little safer than dying all right I know
what I book next professor Ashok
Srinivasan from the department of
computer science at the University of
West Florida thank you so much for your
time thank you're welcome
time for your questions now over to our
science correspondent Derek Williams
when we have a vaccine how can we
provide enough shots to inoculate
everyone is there a plan to coordinate
efforts around the globe there are now
over 120 different kovat 19 vaccine
candidates and studies going on around
the world and based on a range of
technologies some developers are so
confident of success that they're
they're already making plans for
large-scale production the most likely
scenario is that we'll need more than
one successful vaccine to meet global
demand and and it could well be that
different demographics like like
children or the elderly respond better
or worse to particular vaccines so so
the shotgun approach is actually being
viewed as a positive thing in late April
the w-h-o launched an international
initiative called the access to Kovan 19
tools accelerator it's aimed at
coordinating global efforts and and
ensuring equal access to any drugs or
vaccines that are developed but several
key countries most notably the US have
not come out in support of it is there a
difference between PCR tests and iliza
tests a PCR or polymerase chain reaction
test is a method for from multiplying
and tagging small amounts of genetic
material like like RNA from a swab
sample taken for example from your nose
or your throat PCR is the primary method
used to determine the presence of SARS
co2 so whether someone has an active
kovat 19 infection ELISA
which stands for enzyme linked
immunosorbent assay is is what's called
a serological tests it's it's a blood
test for detecting antibodies made by
your immune system in response to the
virus and they take awhile for the body
to produce so so PCR tests
tell you if you're currently infected
while ELISA tells you if you might have
had the disease already at some point in
the past how come our experience with
pandemics like SARS Ebola and HIV didn't
help us stop kovat 19 right away since
the SARS epidemic we've had over 15
years to prepare for another fast
spreading deadly new respiratory illness
caused by a corona virus many experts
said over and over that a disease like
Ovid 19 was inevitable that it wasn't a
question of if it would happen but but
when and what did we do to prepare not
much the most you can say is that we
didn't have to start completely from
scratch because a few labs did pursue
coronavirus research during the last
decade and a half especially after the
advent of MERS but the pharmaceuticals
industry largely lost interest and and
that's mostly down to the fact that
there just isn't a lot of money to be
made in preparation or preventive
measures that's all Falco b19 special
thanks for watching and before we go a
helpful reminder for those of you
planning to board a plane soon again be
sure to bring wipes with you to
disinfect surfaces plastics zip bags for
personal items like your ID card wash
your hands as often as possible stay in
your seat and wear a mask and in either
case have a safe flight thanks for
watching
[Music]